we're going to talk about different
people who are going to take money off
you and why they're going to do that
okay sorry
well that's this is the reality of
buying a car okay so the first thing
we're going to do is I'm going to tell
you about the three groups of people who
you're going to have to pay money to you
might be able to guess what some of them
ah you don't want to give a suggestion
okay number one or the first one you
want to put down I'm gonna write the
government I'm gonna put that here in
the middle you'll see why in a second
you do have to pay the government a
substantial amount of money but not the
biggest amount it is the biggest amount
of money go to yeah very okay yes so the
the catch-all word for that that I'm
gonna give it is that dealership now I'm
going to say dealership and not worry
too much about if you were an individual
buying off another individual like my
first two cars which were both bought
secondhand off of an individual so we're
gonna go with I'm gonna call a
dealership you might say for example
because of my bias towards Japanese cars
you might say classical Toyota that's a
dealership okay and you have to pay them
the lion's share of the money you're
paying for this car now there's one last
group W Twitter okay it sure as insurers
they are the people who are going to
take a little sums of money off you over
a long period of time to ensure you
whatever that means we'll get to that in
a second okay yes that's not cool are
you okay oh yeah well maybe maybe
possibly okay so I give me some examples
of interest okay Amy who else
enter ma gir le answers GI you all this
list of people okay see you get the idea
yes they they advertise a lot okay so
now let's think about what are you
actually paying for cuz to each of these
groups of people conveniently you're
basically paying two things to each one
okay
so let's again go through like what's
the biggest sum of money the actual
biggest online it's the car itself right
so we would call that the
tell price okay so when we say retail
price if you're watching a TV ad and
they're like you know twenty nine ninety
drive away that's that number okay that
number there is the actual price of the
car and then you know this is like a
little asterisk next to twenty nine
ninety well we're going to talk about
that it's actually not little at all
it's a very big asterisk okay so yeah
we'll talk about that it's that you can
pay for the car but you can't have it
okay I'll talk about that in a minute
now
firstly there's the price of the car
itself but then they have to we'll get
to that in a minute
the other thing you pay to the
dealership is not registration that'll
come up coming later but the price is
actually getting the car to you so we
called that generally speaking dealer
delivery so for example one of the cars
I almost bought was actually Karin
camera so that car's got to get from
Canberra to me and I'm not going to go
there to get it so I have to pay for the
delivery okay alright now before we move
into these other kinds of things we pay
for let's talk about these things and
what their purposes are so firstly
retail price that's really simple that's
just well what's the car worth what is
the value of the car you buy a bigger
car you buy a newer car yeah absolutely
very practical okay that's what that
goes into the retail price okay
plus a hefty profit margin for obviously
whichever company is manufacturing it
there's value for car but totally
separate from that there is that the
processing the paperwork all that kind
of stuff in order to prepare the vehicle
that's what the dealer delivery includes
okay so I would call that for assessing
and things like you know they're gonna
put mats in your car they might have to
do a safety check at the beginning
before they hand the car over because if
you like drive out of that dealership
with a brand new car and then the wheels
all fall off and you you know get in an
accident
guess who's liable right yeah it
actually happens okay so these are the
simple cost now I will point out when we
say drive away usually what that means
is both of these things together but
that's usually what it's referring to
so it's like yeah we'll get the car and
we'll also give it to you so that's
that's drive away okay
however you can't legally drive away and
you can physically drive away but you
can't legally drive way until you've
paid a few other things okay so let's
now talk about the government um people
mentioned registration already
registration
okay now the registration of a car we'll
talk about it some purpose in a minute
and it has an informal name it's often
called a pink slip does anyone know why
it's called a pink slip because when you
fill out the form if you're on the line
there is a pink piece of paper okay so
that's why they call it your you've got
to go for your pink slip okay now we'll
talk about what the purpose of that is
in a second but there's one other thing
that needs to pay they want to know what
else needs to be pay it also applies to
property and real estate if you buy that
it's a percentage it's got a strange
name it's called stamp duty now
stamp duty stand duty is exactly what it
sounds like you're literally playing for
the government to put a stamp on a
series of paperwork's that's thats
related to your car I'm going to talk
about what they are in a minute